[Música]
escala en París Aída palao
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
es conocida mundialmente por su faceta
musical ha ganado cuatro premios Grammys
Latinos y dos MTV Euro Music Awards es
la cantante chilena con más proyección
internacional pero hoy nos viene a
hablar de otra de sus facetas artísticas
la pintura recibimos en escala en París
Amón laferte mon bienvenida Y muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros Gracias a
ti ayuda mon laferte acompañada por
berghan costume de la Galería Bahía
utópica de Valparaíso han hecho el viaje
a París para participar en la feria
internacional de arte urbano Distrito 13
que se celebra en el prestigioso hotel
Duo y no es la primera vez que Bahía
utópica trae cuadros de lafertea a París
Y a lo hicieron la pasada edición de
Distrito 13 pero sí que es la primera
vez que Mon laferte está presente en la
feria siente que en una fase distinta en
el mundo del arte con esta vitrina
Parisina sí totalmente es mi Es la
primera vez que vengo a París a mostrar
mi arte
y estoy súper
emocionadísima porque claro París es la
ciudad del arte entonces poder presentar
mis obras aquí en una feria tan
importante además de de
Street arts no que es también
bastante actual creo yo no es como
Mostrar lo que hago pero en un contexto
hoy las calles están invadidas y
ocupadas por el artista también es algo
que que me gusta mucho porque no solo
pinta el Lienzo Si tan sino que también
se ha lanzado a hacer murales no en las
calles sí creo que es uno de los de las
expresiones de arte Hoy que más me
emociona que es como que el arte puede
llegar fácilmente a toda la gente ya no
está solo en las Galerías o en los
museos sino que también está ahí para
para ser visto y apreciado por todo el
mundo porque Hizo unos murales en
valparaísos y no me equivoco he hecho la
ayuda de un Dúo que también va a estar
presente en esta feria no sí sí he
tenido colaboraciones con con los chicos
de un color distinto que son unos
artistas de Valparaíso he hecho murales
en Chile en México hice uno de los
Ángeles he tenido algo de experiencia
moral
Bahía utópica que Apuesta por el
Street Art desde la Meca chilena no del
arte urbano que es Valparaíso
trae aparte de las propuestas del
hacerte a otros artistas chilenos la
jpeñeira Love Sant Journey Christian
Castillo la dupla de arte Ur justamente
de la que hablábamos un color distinto y
el muralista de ti en cristofanini son
artistas con mucha personalidad algunos
ya con una gran trayectoria reconocidos
que tienen en común todos estos artistas
tienen en común primero de coincidir con
la línea de la feria de arte urbano son
artistas que no son necesariamente
oriundo del del de la técnica del arte
urbano del Street Art pero tiene todo
cumplen con los requisitos de una línea
que va muy mucho con el pop o con
elástico urbano en la calle de la
callejero entonces un color distinto la
dupla gracias a ellos no encontramos y
conocimos a Mon laferte ellos ellos son
Realmente uno de los mejores artistas
callejeros con un gran murales en
Valparaíso esta vez no pudieron venir
porque tuvieron una guagua Entonces no
no podían viajar y tenemos que él es
académico de las Bellas sacias al
principio pero que se te puede estar
salud en el trabajo
me dijeron que trabaja con cinta Y
tenemos artistas que son pintores pero
que van a desarrollar temáticas
sobre Lienzo clásico pero con técnica
con temática pop u personaje que son muy
importantes en el mundo del Street Art
entonces ahí nosotros éramos una
conmuculatoria hacemos una selección de
seis artista y vamos con este conjunto y
Con mon laferte el trabajo como la
conocimos primero como muralista y
después nos mostró su Lienzo su pintura
su trabajo encontramos que era bueno
presentarla ahí lo hicimos el año pasado
la serie anterior que finalmente se hizo
en enero Entonces repetimos esta vez y
esta vez vino además con Lienzo que si
son más
trabajado como Street Art con mucha
intervención con mucha graffiti y hay
una información importante que mañana
también Ramón va a pintar en vivo en la
feria entonces ahí dice porque la feria
organizó liberó un muro dentro del Dúo
que va a dejarlo a los artistas que
participan de la feria para hacer un
gran cada aquí donde cada uno va a tener
un pedazo de muro mañana va a pintar en
vivo disfrutar de del trabajo en directo
de Demon como artista plástica Bueno
usted empezó la carrera como música no
como cantante
pero siempre ha pintado o sea se la
conoce más con música ahora ya como como
pintura también pero pinta o dibuja
desde muy pequeñita cuando siente la
necesidad de decir Bueno pues voy a
compartir lo que estoy haciendo No sí
realmente
siempre he estado toda la vida ha estado
de la misma manera que he estado cerca
de la música Perdón he estado también
pintando o sea ha sido al mismo tiempo
Solo que no lo había compartido con el
mundo
como la música es algo más
como fácil directamente yo de niña
cantaba en una fiesta y era como Ay qué
bonito canta o sacaba la guitarra tenía
una respuesta más inmediata entonces era
más fácil compartirlo pero la pintura de
pronto no es como que uno saca una
pintura y dice miren no sino que es un
momento mucho más
Solitario personal íntimo Entonces
no lo había compartido y llegó un
momento en que decidí compartirlo porque
tenía demasiada obra
tenía una habitación llena de obra y yo
dije Bueno yo tengo que hacer algo con
todo esto tengo que mostrarlo al mundo y
empezar a
compartirlo y
fue hace no sé que seis años fue ya
cuando estaba en México De hecho se ve
mucho la influencia mexicana en sus
obras lo hemos incluso a la Virgen de
Guadalupe en alguno de sus cuadros
Virgen de Guadalupe que lleva también en
la mano
Sin México no habría mon laferte O al
menos estamos en la oferta y pintura
o sea
pinto desde que soy pequeña pero pero
México tiene una gran influencia
obviamente vivo hace 15 años en México
entonces en todo mi arte que yo no lo
separo para mí es todo lo mismo
yo me Expreso y ya sea la música la
pintura pero
México tiene una gran influencia porque
México es es súper colorido tiene mucha
cultura Y entonces es bien difícil que
eso no no se impregne en mi obra en mi
sentir mi corazón hay una representación
recurrente de sus cuadros que es una
niña o una mujer son autorretratos
sí son
más que autorretratos de mi
físicamente tiene que ver Muchos son
tienen que ver con esa con esa niñita
que todos llevamos
Y
eso
también escribe no hablábamos antes de
que bueno hay un poco de graffiti en los
cuadros escribe frases hay una de las
propuestas en las que escribe
dígame explíquenos
si ha estado haciendo mucho ruido
justamente porque
siempre hay comentarios a través de
redes en donde te nombran y te dicen lo
primero que hacen para ofenderte como
mujeres decirte Y entonces ha
estado haciendo mucho de comí y empecé a
recordar todas las veces que me han
dicho a lo largo de mi vida incluso
hay gente cercana la gente querida
me acuerdo mucho de las palabras de mi
abuela que ella Desde el amor pero de
una ignorancia me decía que no saliera a
la calle vestida así porque me podía
pasar algo malo y que me podían tratar
como una y como esta culpabilidad
que tenemos que las mujeres que se que
yo sentía a lo largo de mi vida Que si
me agarraban las nalgas en la calle o me
gritaban algo Yo decía a lo mejor es mi
culpa porque llevo minifalda porque me
vestí como que ha cambiado esto o está
cambiando que sigue igual creo
por lo menos somos más conscientes creo
yo creo que estamos hablamos de esto no
antes era algo que ni siquiera se
hablaba
qué encuentran la pintura que no le da
la música
[Aplausos]
la pintura me da unos momentos de
éxtasis de gloria
en solitario en silencio que es algo que
a veces la música no no lo encuentro tan
fácil que sí sí está cuando estoy en el
estudio que es un trabajo solitario y
meditativo pero el escenario es todo
explosión y la pintura es mucho más
un proceso muy íntimo no del principio
lento contemplativo y es un tipo de
Éxtasis que encuentro ahí pero más
meditativo
En qué corriente inscribiría la
propuesta de mon laferte
lo corriente y los historiadores del
arte lo describen después cuando ha
pasado las cosas
más allá del oficio del amor porque se
nota nosotros como empezamos a invitarla
a exponer nos dimos cuenta que ella
sabía pintar se notaba que pintaba desde
mucho tiempo hay cosas que no son
casuales que se repiten entonces hay
firmas la forma de pintar los ojos pero
lo lado moderno va con la temática y va
con los color utilizado en la libertad
tiene una libertad
y que son casi envidiosos dicen Oye pero
el amor pinta con una libertad que
nosotros no tenemos cómo lo hace Cómo se
les da la autorización de escribir
encima de la tela como darle tanto color
cuando Bueno hay una influencia así
mexicana fuerte esas es cierto Se nota
si uno presenta un trabajo creen que
mexicano siendo talla muchas cosas Bueno
de hecho ya lo es porque tiene la
nacionalidad me comentaba no pero
después nosotros como quería siempre no
preocupamos también del discurso y del
contenido que dan los artistas entonces
trabajamos un poco con acisa que son
puro decorativo nos gusta cuando viene
un discurso detrás que viene algo y con
amor eso también Entonces tal vez
tendremos pronto un corriente que
tendría a la vez un contenido porque
también un chato activismo el feminismo
y todo eso Entonces yo no la voy a
cantar legalizar los expertos podrían
catalizar lo que hago es la monstruo
porque vale la pena nos queda muy poco
tiempo yo les quería preguntar por ese
no a la constitución en Chile porque qué
mona ha estado muy comprometida
socialmente con el estallido social y
con todo este proceso muy brevemente
esto no ha servido para nada o es un
punto y final un punto y aparte o un
punto y seguido muy brevemente voy a ser
muy breve quiero decir que estoy muy
triste me puse muy triste el día de las
elecciones con el resultado creo que a
los humanos nos cuesta mucho Nos da
miedo salir de la zona de Confort y el
miedo siempre es un enemigo y nos
paraliza y entiendo por qué la gente
tuvo miedo
pero yo creo que aún así es un avance Lo
importante es que en la primera votación
la gente en Chile dijo No quiero esta
Constitución no quiero la Constitución
de pinochet Quiero una nueva
constitución esta no fue el también hubo
mucha fake news pero
será otra yo yo tengo
en Puebla Ahora
nos queda más tiempo nos queda el tema
para este debate para para otra ocasión
Les deseamos
muchísima suerte con este proyecto
pictórico y también con su faceta
musical mon laferte Y muchísimas gracias
También a dejan autopica muchísimas
gracias y también a ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rf y mundo.com y
en France 24.com Hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tanta falta de querer
[Música]